[Music]  marker  all hands on deck except you danny  because we're going out tonight but  everybody else  because from now on  we're in a volunteer  tough titties said the kitties when the  milk went dry so  sorry i'd actually like to be your  official girlfriend  i think  people have always told me the only way  i'm making it out the hood is by picking  up a ball or a microphone  like larry bird or eminem like larry  bird or eminem  [Music]  if my doctor didn't say any sudden  movement i cause good  i named my son mac because there was a  marathon  i mean i named my son mac after a  macgyver marathon  okay well you better be careful before  you turn around there'll be another  light one more time dexter there is not  one other light skinned mrs coleman  stop crying and watch a children's movie  like a man  and if it's cool  and through oh this yeah okay you made  it on my mark  [Music]  bayside hasn't  what  jesus  his mom might let him watch show girls  tonight  [Music]  you